hier soir un an et demi après le premier
procès marie-rose bletterie et ses
enfants ont visionné un nouveau la
séquence dans laquelle pascal jardin
s'accuse du viol et du meurtre de
christelle ses aveux passés en septembre
2014 et qu'il qualifie désormais de faux
aveux ce matin marie-rose bletterie est
venu à la barre pour parler de
christelle important aujourd'hui de
rendre hommage à christelle suis pas
très une très bonne oratrice je sais pas
j'ai parlé avec mon coeur j'ai essayé
c'est aussi avec beaucoup d'émotion
c'est pas évident ces jeux les faits
voilà j'espère avoir cuit pas et
christelle et de notre famille une
famille littéralement dévastée par la
mort insupportable de cette jeune fille
sa maman parle d'elle simplement elle
décrit avec tendresse une jeune adulte à
la fois réservé et pleine de vie qui
avait choisi de devenir puéricultrice
ses mots marie-rose bletterie les
adresses aux jurés mais aussi à l'accusé
jeu qui comprennent et s'il ya un peu
d'humanité peut-être pourra peut-être
ensuite à bout et si je lui tend la
perche
si villepin il veut pas et de freins
probablement pas marie-rose bletterie
s'est adressé directement une seule fois
à pascal jardin à la toute fin de sa
déposition
c'est quand elle lui dit qu'il a été
arraché à sa famille je lui demande que
du christ elle n'a pas répondu il
répondra pas restait la plus humble et
arracher sa famille c'est elle qui a été
arraché sa famille lui il a encore sa
famille est encore vivant il pu en
profiter il pu avoir des vite parloir
christine elle ne peut pas pour la
famille ce procès représente la dernière
épreuve d'un parcours de 22 ans
il s'achèvera mercredi prochain